evacuation operations are once again
underway at kabul airport
the nato partners of the us scaling up
their presence
and the u.s department of defense says
within the next 24 hours there will be
up to 6 000 s soldiers in place to
maintain airport security
the pentagon insisting that order has
been restored
right now we're looking at one aircraft
per hour in and out of hkia
we predict that our best effort could
look like 5 000 to 9 000 passengers
departing per day we have had no hostile
interactions no attack and no threat
by the taliban
the deadline for complete withdrawal of
forces and civilians is still the end of
the month a date set by president biden
earlier this year the commander-in-chief
made it very clear that we were going to
complete this drawdown by august 31st
and that which now includes the drawdown
of uh american citizens you know the
pulling out of american citizens and
drawdown of our embassy personnel so
that's what we're focused on that's the
timeline we're on uh and as the
secretary made clear uh to to leaders
even as recently as this morning time is
of the essence and we all we all share a
sense of urgency here the biden
administration continues to defend the
decision to go ahead with the withdrawal
arguing that the alternative was
escalating u.s involvement in another
country's civil war what has unfolded
over the past month has proven
decisively that it would have taken a
significant american true presence
multiple times greater than what
president biden was handed to stop a
taliban onslaught
and we would have taken casualties
american men and women would have been
fighting and dying once again in
afghanistan
both republicans and democrats have been
highly critical of the manner in which
the withdrawal is being conducted
arguing that the chaos that has ensued
constitutes a huge failure of
intelligence
thanks so much everyone the criticism
and the questions
are unlikely to continue
for months to come
my khana al jazeera washington